يتوافد الحجاج المغاربه على مكاتب ختم
الجوازات ورفع البصمات من قبل السلطات
السعوديه في مطار الملك محمد الخامس في
المغرب
بسرعه الحمد لله كل شيء مزيان الامور كلها
بخير وعلى خير والناس مزيانين كل شيء
والحمد لله يمدون يد المساعده تكامل في
الخدمات بين السلطات السعوديه والمغربيه
مرافقه لضيوف الرحمن في كل المراحل من
تسجيل الحقائب وفي بوابات التفتيش وفي
مكاتب ختم الجوازات خدمات كانت رائعه
والحمد لله اللي ربي كرمنا بهاد النعمه ان
شاء الله
جميع الحجاج ان شاء الله غادي يكونوا
فرحانين الحمد لله كل شيء في احسن ظروف
والحمد لله احنا وصلنا وحطينا الباكج
ديالنا وكل احسن الظروف واحد الشعور
ماكيتوصلش
مسلم من هذاك المكان امتعه الحجاج
المغاربه تخضع للترميز وللفرز في المطار
المغربي فيما ارسال الامتعه فتقوم به
السلطات السعوديه الى فنادق اقامه الحجاج
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بثلاثه وفي دقائق قليله تنتهي الاجراءات
ويجد الحاج نفسه في صارت الانتظار قبل
صعود الطائره هذه هي طريق مكه عادل
الزبيري العربيه من مطار مدينه الدار
البيضاء المغربيه
لمتابعه المزيد
من الامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات